um so the last season of Drake and Josh
then that you're
1718 yes
1718 and at that time what year is it
it's uh
2005 okay yeah so J Drake and Josh ends
and then and and you're kind of getting
speed wobbles because you're totally
loaded but uh after Jak Drake and Josh
are you working I was I went and did
this Jud appat movie like right after
and again that was on some standup when
I was 10 years old [__] I remember
auditioning for that movie it's called
drill bit Taylor playing a bully and on
the ride there I go I think I'm going to
do a dice impression for my entire
audition an Andrew Dice Clay impression
like no one it's a strong Choice it's a
heavy claim no one goes like maybe you
do one line in a dice voice like gay you
don't do the whole thing like like and I
did the whole thing in a dice impression
and literally like it was one of those
moments where I think I was so Fearless
that they were they were like this was
either genius or terrible but we'll go
with genius and I get this part and I'm
doing this thing and it was great except
I was like 19 and being a knucklehead
cliche and I just didn't I didn't show
up for the opportunity and that was sort
of like the beginning of of the the of
the quick you know Express train the
sobriety yeah yeah that was that was not
a proud one so you did get the part
though yeah I got the part I did it but
I just was I didn't show up yeah yeah
I'm in the movie you can see it you're
just saying you didn't show up you
were't there 100% no it was a great
opportunity and it's not like Jed appow
likes funny Jewish
guys like it's not like I was perfectly
set up to make the kind of relationship
that could have paid dividends for the
rest of my life no I just I wasn't I
just wasn't there and I didn't know I
was I had just finished this thing that
had defined me for the last 18 years and
like most kids at that age I wanted to
have my college experience and not have
to worry about supporting my mom or not
have to worry about you know doing
something that was going to hurt me in
the public eye
and to an extent I had that but
unfortunately I had this like grownup
job where I needed to show up for people
and I didn't so luckily Jud who was
incredibly cool then is still incredibly
cool and we've chatted about it since
and thankfully I've been able to make an
amends and it's all good you know the
movie didn't suffer just cuz good old JP
didn't bring his aame but um but it was
a good it taught me a lot nice dude so
so you're totally
loaded after this movie and uh like is
there is there an intervention where
people step in and say dude like you
know we're losing you it was so many
instances it was like so many mini
bottoms of just like morally and
emotionally just feeling like to your
point that we talked about earlier like
I was um because I was a heavier kid I
had seen there was a lot of data like
had I just started messing around with
stuff at 18 like I probably would have
had to put together a stronger portfolio
against myself you know like a a
stronger defense of saying like hey bud
it's clearly not working out but I
literally had 10 years of data saying
Josh you overdo it no matter what it is
you overdo it like you aren't like your
fellows and and it started with you know
me being heavier when I was younger and
then I got in shape and I thought I'd
hit this Finish Line but of course I had
the same mind and so I just needed
something something different so when I
found you
know uh sort of uh all all the the
tricks and trades of of the things that
people like us like to indulge in it was
like it was a wrap I was like oh this is
so much better and S such fewer calories
wow I I I don't know that I've uh heard
of the things we do in recovery as
indulgent but yeah it's it's way better
did did I hear you right that you said
said you got in shape before you got
sober yeah oh wow I lost yeah I lost a
considerable amount before wow I I was
under the impression that it was a more
recent thing that you had your
transformation no no like uh almost 20
years ago 300 lb as a kid I was a big
boy yeah yeah my wife keeps saying like
you don't have to talk about it that
much I'm like the people they love
it she's like you know you're never
going to escape it if you keep talking
about it I'm like it's good podcast yeah
yeah
thumbnail just put my old face right
here yeah do you like shopping on Amazon
I do and good news is sto's butt wipes
for your butthole are available on
Amazon and if you want a real bundle of
a deal you can get sto's hot sauce for
your butthole plus sto's butthole
destroyer and steo butt wipes for your
butthole it's the butthole but
available on Amazon right
now yeah dude